i'm taking the mic baby it's been nearly
three decades since adam levine took the
mic and began his musical career hello
my name is adam this is james and that's
ryan and we're maroon 5. e.t has been
with adam and his band maroon 5 since
they burst onto the scene in the early
2000s it feels
surreal
interesting
at times
perplexing
but um we all love it and we appreciate
it and we're happy you know it's been a
really
charmed year and we're very
fortunate to have experienced it we're
uh we're big in 2004. the reason for
that maroon 5's debut album songs about
jane which included this smash hit
[Music]
then came the recognition from billboard
it's great man we won a very cool award
and i had a great time had some drinks
to the recording academy a grammy is a
grammy as a grammy they even beat out
kanye west for best new artist at the
grammys in 2005. et was backstage for
their reaction kanye did win this i i
feel like he had something to do with
this i feel like he's part of this he's
gonna win enough awards tonight yeah it
went like i told him i said i told him
the other day i was like listen man you
can win like seven or eight of them oh
there's gonna be right now um we can
just take one since then adam has led
the band to win two additional grammys
three american music awards eight
billboard music awards and many others
something that we take a lot of pride in
so we're really happy about it adam has
seven studio albums under his belt with
maroon
i want that red velvet i want that sugar
sweet don't let nobody touch it unless
that somebody's me and in 2020 the
group's music was named one of the most
played of the entire 2010s
outside of music the los angeles native
has ventured onto our screens most
notably as a coach on nbc's the voice
for 16 seasons now i think all i can do
is just have fun
coach them coach them to the end right
he also appeared in season two of
american horror story admit it i'm the
best you've ever had i have no idea how
i got here but i like it here in 2014 he
made his major film debut ironically as
a singer in the rom-com begin again
opposite kira knightley i just you know
greta is very much part of the
inspiration behind everything this was
the first kind of substantial thing that
i was offered that was a real part and
not just a cameo or something like that
and
i just got so lucky adam's
accomplishments have even earned him a
spot on the hollywood walk of fame it's
one of the most
incredible special
days of my life that i will never ever
forget a hosting gig at studio 8h what a
tremendous honor to be here hosting
saturday night live and in 2019 he and
his band headlined to the super bowl
halftime show biggest gig in the game
right adam's shirtlessness nearly broke
the internet how'd he prepare for that
moment adam only told et i've been
treating it like i'm about to play in
the super bowl myself
working out a lot you know keeping
taking care of myself for the past 30
days with his moves like jagger and his
abs of steel it's no wonder the funny
man even holds 2013's title as sexiest
man alive now with my clothes are on
no no nudity today
try to stay classy now sorry to break
your hearts ladies this man is taken by
former victoria's secret model bahati
prince luke and i'm really proud of her
and she's proud of me it all works
there's no ego the two tied the knot in
2014 and now share two kids dusty rose
and geo grace i love
i love kids
[Music]